In the ornate Spanish hall, the two countries agreed to downsize their arsenals.
Presidents Barack Obama and Dmitry Medvedev signed their country's first major nuclear arms pact...
...in almost two decades.
Mr. Obama said the treaty is a big step forward for world security.
Today's an important milestone for nuclear security and nonproliferation,...
...and for U.S.-Russia relations.
Speaking through an interpreter, the Russian leader said the yearlong negotiations were tough...
...but hard work on both sides brought success.
That enabled us to do something, that in just a couple of months,...
...looked like mission impossible.
Within a short span of time, we prepared a full-fledged treaty and signed it.
The pact requires the US and Russia to cut their inventory of nuclear warheads...
...by about 1/3 in the next seven years.
The agreement also slashes by more than half the number of missiles,...
...submarines and bombers that carry the weapons.
Mr. Obama says in addition,...
...the treaty paves the way for future arms reduction talks with Russia...
...mainly on short-range nuclear weapons.
This treaty will set the stage for further cuts.
And going forward, we hope to pursue discussions with Russia...
...on reducing both our strategic and tactical weapons,...
...including non-deployed weapons.